j'habite dans le froid
il n'a plus ni père ni mère
il habitait dans les bois
il nous connaît
jeux divers
oui mais s'il part aux oiseaux
les oiseaux comme les oiseaux puis cuit
moi qu'est ce que tu avais des oiseaux
n'intéresse pas le public les oiseaux
mais bon faut oublier complètement les
oiseaux nombre d'étapes et le petit
bedon
le normand girard à toulouse i celle ci
alors écoute moi j'ai dans le normand
ouimet tu peux pas faire le succès avec
un nom comme ça j'adore c'est pas bon
les normands c'est pas bon ne va pas non
il funcom viliame jaune pétel tous
choisis par exemple beau voyage ça c'est
mon mode froid hier ça non qu'est ce
qu'un coffret hier aussi beau ça se fait
le succès ça c'est un occupant fliers il
connaît le succès de ces depuis quarante
ans les quatre picador vous connaît les
quatre canots espagne espagne a cessé
moi c'est moi c'est lui analyse la baule
et les jongleurs
ça te connais c'est moi aussi alors bon
et cochon bien j'ai tapé le boeuf
maintenant alors les oiseaux c02 dit
avec lui les oiseaux c'est zéro c'est ça
ou alors il faut faire les feelings des
voix qu'est ce que c'est le feeling oui
on fait tu vois sellette les senteurs de
sable mêlé sinatra france et le preneur
quoi si ce site dit le coroner
c'est parce que tu as un peu les
physiques de crooner et tu peux faire le
physique était pour faire le connaître
écoute moi tout va mettre ça sur le dos
droit y est tout
nous nous sommes dit dernier
oui
wydad
ce soir là
c'est à lui qu'on sait bien sûr c'est
pas du passé puisque c'est une chanson
américaine c'est un standard avec ses
blue moon tout la secte moon non mais
comment je vais tout donner sur ces
faits les succès tranquille assassins ne
faut pas lâcher nos coûts nos rives
était dit ou fait pas tout fait pas du
tout le crooner parce que c'est avant
tout fait les rockeurs parce que ça
c'est bon ça fait 6 ou 10 10 le rockeur
tout s'efface qui trompait l'esthétique
d'euros alors que paraît comme bloquée
quand la mousson un couteau défiler à
tours
c'est pas ça c'est un truc qui swingue
normal alors coupé pas les rockets
parce que je suis étonné tout dit ou
fait l'échangé de messages par des
hommes sa toile et physique un peu pour
les moteurs à les messages les deux de
tech3 commissariat je connais ce que
j'écris et puis tout fait les messages
tout du fossé
il était dit je suis chez moi mais alors
là je peux pas être accompagné par
n'importe qui là il faut je pense qu'on
a vite mais merci madame suzie
quand wali tôt il nous parlait c'est aux
tripes que ça nous prenait quand il
disait
j'en ai ras-le-bol ça voulait dire j'en
ai ras-le-bol
on était d'accord pas d'accord mais
fallait pas rester au banc j'avais des y
avaient pris ras et tous les mac du
barbara y avait une console mais c'est
bon bon moi j'ai pas dis se multiplient
dans les tripes ils vendent
il veut te dit de ne pas trop ne tenez
pas roquettes les sentez l'âme et à tout
va les clés chapiteau la rolls tout ça
dans les messages
ces messages si je suis fait pour le
messin laroche knowlton libéré à ce le
rôle suis it aurait pas cent balles des
fois non